okay
i am glad to be joined by my colleagues
uh senators heinrich and king
uh we may be further senator carper was
going to join us to talk about the water
bill but he has to be on the floor to
speak about it and senator duckworth
will be joining us we think shortly as
will senator markey
and there he is okay um so
if after one of the
most difficult years in recent memory
the first hundred days of the biden
presidency and the new senate democratic
majority
has seen the country turn a corner
slowly
but surely we are proving to the
american people
that government and the senate can work
for them
and we're seeing shots in people
vaccines in people's arms
we're seeing money in their pockets
we're seeing small businesses and
restaurants
open up we have
begun in a very good way and this week
is no exception we have a lot to do by
the end of the week
we'll confirm several more highly
qualified nominees
to the executive branch our senate
committees will continue holding
hearings and markups
on at least a dozen other nominees the
senate will also consider
two important bipartisan environmental
infrastructure policies this week
first and senator carper couldn't be
here to talk about it
but he's done a great job along with
ranking member capito
and senators duckworth who i think will
be here and cardin
and we'll take up the drinking water and
wastewater infrastructure act
of 2021 it passed through epw
with unanimous support
and what's very interesting about it and
bodes well for
some bipartisanship and build back
better the
plan that the republican senator sent to
the president has almost the exact
language that we are voting on
on the floor um so that's a good thing
and we have both sides of the aisle have
an opportunity to do amendments just as
we did with the anti-hate crimes bill
um on a topic as straightforward as this
i hope our republican colleagues will
cooperate so that we can move the bill
quickly we don't need a lot of
killer amendments gotcha amendments
things not relevant to the bill things
just to delay
it's going to pass and we want to get it
done this week
second the second bill is a major major
victory for those of us who want to
deal with global warming in this in a
very strong way
and that is a vote on the methane cra
the three folks here surrounding me
senators heinrich king
and marky have worked very hard on this
and they'll talk more about it
but it is uh very important
i want to be clear the methane cra is a
big deal
the rate not only drew chi the the rule
rather not only drew cheers from the
environmental community
but also has the support of industry as
well
it's going to help us address the
climate crisis in a major way
methane warms the atmosphere 86 times
more than a ton
a ton of methane uh is 87
absorbs 86 percent more oxygen
than a ton of carbon dioxide
the senate will send a decisive message
by re-imposing
these common sense rules to reduce
methane emissions
last week president biden set an
ambitious goal
for the us to cut greenhouse gas
emissions in half by the end of the
decade
this is the first of many steps many
important steps the senate will take to
achieve that goal
senator heinrich
thank you leader schumer why is this
such a big deal
as he said uh methane is 86 times more
potent
than co2 but it doesn't stick around
that long in the atmosphere so if we do
this
if we stop venting if we stop flaring
if we stop leaking at the wellhead if we
stop leaking
in the pipelines that connect the rest
of the country
we can have an enormous impact on
how much our atmosphere warms and
i it was pretty instructive to me to
look at the modeling
and to see that between
hydrofluorocarbons that senator carbon
led the
senator carper led the the charge on
earlier this year
and methane leakage we can take a huge
chunk out of the global warming budget
for the next few years so this is an
enormous opportunity
um if you're in industry this is an
opportunity to keep more of your product
and sell more of your product
this is absolutely common sense and my
hope
is it would be broadly bipartisan
because when you have so many of the
world's major oil and gas producers
on the same side as the entire
environmental community
you would think this would be a
no-brainer senator king
controlling methane is the low-hanging
fruit
of combating climate change it is the
simplest
most direct most cost-effective way that
we can combat
climate change not 10 years from now 15
years from now or even five years from
now
now with this passage of the cra
tomorrow which would repeal the repeal
we will have a significant regulatory
regime
on the release of methane into the
atmosphere from drilling
and from pipelines as senator heinrich
mentioned
this is supported by many in the
industry not all but many
for the simple reason a they think it's
effective and two
it is cost effective this is not this is
not
a a highly
a high cost option this is something
that can be done at a reasonable cost
and the payback is enormous
so this is a really this is a major bill
in fact i would argue that if we can
pass this tomorrow would be the most
significant climate change bill
that we've passed around here in many
years it may
it may seem like a it's this regulatory
thing
cra but this is an enormous opportunity
for this country
to take a real solid demonstrable step
on the issue of climate change and
demonstrate
international leadership that is so
important to confronting the problem
that is global in its scope so
i think this is a real opportunity and
uh
i will introduce senator markey who has
been working on this
uh on this subject forever
yeah since yes since methane was first
invented in the lincoln administration
um thank you so much and uh thank you
leader schumer
uh senator heinrich senator king for
your great leadership on this
issue
methane is a silent killer
it is 86 times more powerful and
damaging than co2
over a 20-year period and it now
accounts for more than one-quarter
of all global warming methane pollution
is also a compounding problem it helps
form
the ground-level smog that we breathe
triggering asthma attacks and
aggravating other respiratory conditions
that have already taken center stage
amidst a global
respiratory pandemic even last year
with more cars off the road and many
stuck in their homes methane pollution
levels
kept rising we cannot talk
about combating the climate crisis
without reducing
methane emissions if we are going to put
out the fire
of the climate crisis we have to stop
lighting
matches of methane pollution in our own
country
and then be the example for the rest of
the world
but there are solutions and first we
have to enforce the clean air act
instead of undermining it uh it was uh
for the last four years something that
donald trump tried to
roll back we now have a president and a
congress that believes
in science and this vote on the cra
is something uh that is going to put
science back
again uh and second we have to push our
methane
emissions down even further and faster
than ever before so we have a real
chance here
uh because the fossil fuel industry
knows
um that for a very little amount of
money
it can cap these methane emissions and
it can ultimately be
profitable to them in other words they
can actually pay for
uh the capping of the methane by then
their use of the methane as a commercial
product
and they know it and we have an
excellent chance here to win this cra
and i can't thank um our leaders here
for all the work that they have done
okay we'll take some questions yes
another economic plan the family's plan
is trying to get a sense of
look we want to get as big and bold
action as we can get
and we'll wait for the president to lay
out his plan
um but we want to get as i said this
country
is demanding the average american
needs needs to feel that they have a
really
bright and sunny future something they
haven't felt in a while
and as big a bolder plan as we can get
we're going to get
senator schumer uh your endless frontier
act was pulled from a commerce committee
markup yesterday
tomorrow uh after more than 200
amendments were added to the bill
do you have a sense of which pieces of
the legislation your colleagues
there's lots of amendments this is a
broad comprehensive bill and it's brand
new
uh that we're encouraged that there are
200 they're bipartisan amendments
they're constructive amendments both
uh senator cantwell our chair and
senator wicker our ranking member want
to work through those amendments and
come up with a bipartisan bill
and uh we believe it will be marked up
uh when we get back
and we will put it on the floor in may
thank you obviously the
operations security standpoint protocol
going to be different from the
health and hygiene have they talked to
senators at all as to whether or not
they will have to pass through the
magnetometers to get into the house
chamber or
i'll have to get you the details on that
well i have been informed of all the
security
that is uh being there i feel very safe
being there
i've told my colleagues that and um
they're doing very
they're doing a very good job there's
lots of different levels of security but
i don't know the specific answers to
your questions
no longer well former what do you think
about the bill just introduced by
senator mark you to expand the supreme
court
give me thoughts on it are you open to
it look the bottom line is that i am
waiting to
hear what president biden's commission
says about the supreme court and they're
going to look at many different aspects
a little more than a month ago you vowed
that you would put guns legislation on
the floor background checks legislation
on the floor just wondering if you have
any update on the sentences
yes they do at some point you just have
to say we're gonna vote
whether you're with us or not senator
murphy is making good progress talking
and trying to get some republican
support for that bill
and we hope there's a path forward that
can actually pass
but we will put gun legislation on the
floor period
yes
yes yes thank you everybody
last one again
senator booker is making i just met for
an hour with senators booker and durbin
yesterday
uh they're making good progress with
senator scott uh there's
you know this is a serious problem we
need strong legislation
and we're hopeful that the booker uh
scott negotiations can produce just that
they're making good progress
thank you everybody
no problem
am i clear
you